con el pronunciamiento del consejo
nacional electoral lo único que se
evidencia son las profundas diferencias
que existen entre sus principales
autoridades mientras algunos pedían
retirar el informe que pedía un reconteo
de votos otros consideraban que la
apertura de urnas sólo retrasaría todo
el calendario electoral mientras que las
dos representantes indígenas dentro del
órgano comicial apoyaban seguir adelante
con la apertura de urnas y enfrentar los
comentarios de fraude que existe en la
opinión pública actualmente en ecuador
paralelamente el candidato ya cooper y
se asegura que presentará todos los
recursos que sustenten su tesis de un
supuesto fraude mientras que guillermo
lasso se desmarcó del acuerdo
previamente planteado un diálogo ante el
órgano comicial las organizaciones
indígenas se movilicen en una caminata
hacia la capital ecuatoriana hasta el
órgano electoral en una marcha que han
denominado de resistencia por lo pronto
se espera que el día sábado 20 de
febrero se proclamen los resultados
definitivos y así conocer a los
vencedores de la primera vuelta
electoral para iniciar la campaña de
cara a la segunda vuelta el día 16 de
marzo durante los próximos 45 días todo
un medio de un escenario judicial que
busca descalificar al líder de la
primera vuelta electoral el candidato
andrés zarautz